Bene, buonasera, seconda delle nostre tre donne del Medioevo e a occhio e croce quella che conoscete di meno.
Caterina da Siena, uno l'ha sentita nominare, Giovanna d'Arco, uno più o meno sa chi è, Christine de Pisan invece, magari meno.
No, io avevo già dato il titolo quando mi sono reso conto che forse è più facile se anziché chiamarla col nome con cui è famosa oggi ed era conosciuta anche al suo tempo in Francia,
la chiamiamo col suo vero nome perché questa era un'italiana e si chiamava Cristina da Pizzano, dopodiché è un'italiana che è andata a vivere in Francia da bambina e in Francia ha avuto successo ed è diventata famosa al suo tempo
e tuttora in Francia è studiata, conosciuta, molto più di quanto non sia fra noi.
Però si chiamava Cristina da Pizzano, il quale Pizzano sarebbe un posto sull'Apenino Bolognese, fra parentesi.
Noi parliamo di lei, è l'unica delle nostre tre donne medievali che non sia stata fatta santa a un certo punto, è l'unica che non sia morta giovane perché ha avuto una vicenda straordinaria,
è l'unica che tutto sommato da molti punti di vista è stata una donna normale secondo i criteri del suo tempo, nel senso che si è sposata, ha fatto dei bambini,
avete già capito che è questa la sostanza agli occhi della maggior parte della gente di allora della vita di una donna.
Cristina tuttavia è una donna straordinaria e di cui noi sappiamo un sacco di cose perché è, si può dirlo tranquillamente senza timore di sbagliare,
la prima donna che ha concepito se stessa come scrittrice di professione, che si è mantenuta e ha guadagnato ed è diventata famosa scrivendo libri.
Cristina, si diceva, è italiana, è nata a Venezia nel 1365, per intenderci nel 1365 Caterina da Siena che abbiamo raccontato lungamente ieri è in casa,
ha 18 anni, ormai ha trionfato sulle opposizioni della famiglia, vive la sua vita di mistica e di penitente in casa,
nasce questa bambina figlia di un intellettuale, figlia di maestro Tommaso da Pizzano che è professore di medicina e di astrologia all'università di Bologna
e che poi appunto viene chiamato a insegnare a Venezia e si trasferisce lì e poi nello stesso anno in cui nasce sua figlia Cristina è invitato direi a quello che è il vertice del mondo di allora in Europa
alla corte del re di Francia come medico e astrologo personale del re di Francia Carlo V, il saggio.
Cristina dunque non è figlia di uno qualunque, io qui vorrei fare una piccola digressione perché bisogna cercare di vedere le cose come le vedevano loro,
io mi rendo conto, o almeno io ho l'impressione che quando vi dico medico la cosa fa un certo effetto, non so perché ma mi sembra che quando aggiungo
è astrologo a noi ci caschino un po' le braccia tutto sommato, invece dobbiamo cercare di vedere le cose come le vedono loro.
Per loro un astrologo non è un ciarlatano, per loro un astrologo è uno scienziato e non è un caso se la stessa persona è medico e astrologo
perché loro hanno questa caratteristica, loro vedono l'universo intorno a sé, vedono il cielo stellato, se lo immaginano in modo molto diverso da noi,
non hanno mai sentito parlare del Big Bang, dell'universo in espansione, però vedono questo movimento estremamente complesso di corpi celesti
e hanno questa caratteristica gli uomini del Medioevo, che forse li distingue da noi in qualche misura,
che non riescono a immaginare che sia una roba che non significa niente, che non riescono a immaginare che non voglia dire nulla,
questo enorme meccanismo che vedono muoversi intorno a sé.
Loro poi pensano che questo meccanismo l'abbia creato Dio e Dio avrebbe fatto tutto questo per divertirsi senza scopo?
No, questo non è possibile.
Quindi la gente di allora pensa che questo immenso movimento di corpi celesti, scientifico perché questi movimenti si possono calcolare, predire,
ecco loro pensano che voglia dire qualcosa, pensano che sia un libro in cui Dio ha scritto per parlarci
e chi sa interpretare questi movimenti può capire delle cose e pensano, scusate questa lunga digressione,
ma Cristina è vissuta con un padre che si occupava di queste cose e ha assorbito da lui anche queste cose,
quindi la digressione credo che sia giustificata, pensano che l'universo sia tutto collegato
e che questi corpi celesti abbiano dei collegamenti con i nostri corpi terreni,
ecco perché il medico è anche astrologo,
perché la loro scommessa è di dire scommetto che ci sono dei collegamenti,
che quei corpi celesti influiscono sui nostri corpi terreni
e che se io riesco a indovinare il senso di questi collegamenti posso curare i miei malati
e posso dire al re se questo è il momento buono oppure no per dichiarare guerra
o per portare una certa legge in Parlamento,
perché calcolando quei movimenti posso predire delle cose.
Chiusa digressione, scusatemi, ma era per sottolineare che Cristina non è figlia di un ciarlatano,
è figlia di uno scienziato e di un intellettuale,
il quale scienziato e intellettuale è famoso in Europa ed è chiamato alla Corte di Francia,
ci va, ci rimane per un bel po' di tempo prima di chiamare la famiglia,
aspetta di essere sicuro che la posizione sia buona, solida,
quando si rende conto, Tommaso, che la posizione è solidissima, fa venire la famiglia.
Cristina ha quattro anni, va a vivere a Parigi con il padre e col resto della famiglia.
Parigi è un po' il centro del mondo, non che Venezia o Firenze o Bologna,
in quel 300, siano posti di periferia, tutt'altro,
però Parigi è davvero un po' il centro del mondo cristiano,
il centro della civiltà del tardo medioevo.
Cristina parla, ogni tanto parla nelle sue opere,
di quel che ha voluto dire andare a Parigi,
racconta quel che ha visto questa bambina,
un equilibrista che cammina su una corda
tesa fra le due torri di Notre Dame
e tutta la gente sotto che sta a vedere,
non c'è la rete di sicurezza, naturalmente,
e l'equilibrista cammina fra le due torri di Notre Dame,
che già allora erano uguali a come le vediamo noi oggi, naturalmente.
Oppure, arriva un'ambasciata del sultano d'Egitto
e la bambina, il cui padre è medico del re,
è lì, sui palchi, al posto d'onore,
a vedere arrivare l'ambasciata del sultano d'Egitto,
tutto questo corteo di gente esotica.
Dunque, Cristina ha questa infanzia felice
in casa di un intellettuale
il quale le insegna a leggere e scrivere,
o comunque le fa insegnare a leggere e scrivere.
Chi c'era ieri sera si ricorda Caterina da Siena
non sapeva leggere e scrivere,
ha poi imparato, tardi.
Vedremo domani che Giovanna d'Arco
praticamente non sapeva leggere e scrivere,
neanche lei sapeva fare la firma.
Invece Cristina è una che sa leggere e scrivere,
fin da bambina, la casa è piena di libri,
e lei legge,
e il padre, questo ce lo racconta lei,
il papà era contento che lei leggesse
e che fosse appassionata dei libri,
la mamma meno.
L'abbiamo già incontrato ieri nel caso di Caterina da Siena
questa cosa, che è questa complicità fra padre e figlia,
mentre la mamma rappresenta un po', come dire,
un atteggiamento più convenzionale.
Anche la mamma di Cristina ogni tanto dice
ma a cosa servono tutti questi libri,
tanto tu ti devi sposare e fare dei bambini,
quindi devi saper fare la padrona di casa,
filare la lana.
E infatti Cristina non è
una che a un certo punto ha le visioni
e che decide di fare voto di castità
perché il suo sposo sta lassù.
Cristina è una brava ragazzina
che fa quello che le dicono in casa
e quindi a 15 anni si sposa
con l'uomo che le ha scelto la famiglia.
L'abbiamo accennato ieri sera,
poi chiudo con i rapporti con ieri sera
e mi scuserete.
È il 1380,
è l'anno in cui muore Caterina da Siena
divorata dai suoi digiuni
e forse dalla sua anoressia.
In quello stesso anno
Cristina da Pizzano,
che ormai è diventata Christine de Pizan,
si sposa
con un uomo che ha nove anni più di lei,
come è normale,
e comincia a fargli dei figli.
È un uomo ben piazzato,
segretario del re,
lo stesso ambiente del padre,
la corte,
è gente che conosce il re,
conosce i principi,
conosce i governanti,
sia pure in una posizione un po' subalterna,
e quindi è vicina al vertice della società.
Cristina è moglie, madre,
comincia a far bambini,
è spesso incinta,
ha poco tempo per leggere,
un po' fa,
ce lo dice nelle sue opere successive,
un po' fa il confronto,
è certo che da sposata e da mamma
non è più tanto facile continuare a leggere
come faceva prima,
ma lei fa il suo mestiere di moglie e di madre.
Poi dopo dieci anni di matrimonio,
all'improvviso il marito muore.
Cristina rimane sola,
sola,
c'è la mamma,
soldi ce ne sono,
mezzi ce ne sono,
però rimane lei sola,
il marito è morto,
un marito che lei ha amato moltissimo,
ce lo dice più volte,
del rimpianto di quest'uomo che lei è morto,
della sua decisione di non risposarsi,
questa non è una cosa ovvia,
le vedove si risposavano,
tanto più se come Cristina,
anche se è stata sposata dieci anni,
quando rimane vedova ne ha solo venticinque comunque,
non si risposa,
perché il suo uomo era quello,
le piaceva quello,
non ne vuole un altro,
e però deve farsi carico
di questa famiglia
che suo marito le ha lasciato,
e qui succede la prima cosa
abbastanza stupefacente
nella vita di Cristina,
Cristina ci racconta
in una sua opera
cosa ha voluto dire per lei
restare vedova
e a capo di una famiglia,
ci racconta un sogno,
noi non lo sappiamo
se l'ha sognata davvero questa cosa
o se è un'invenzione letteraria,
se è una sua invenzione
per esprimere quello che ha provato,
va bene in tutti e due i casi,
lo vedete anche voi,
sia che l'abbia sognato davvero,
sia che se lo sia immaginato lei,
cos'è che dice di aver sognato?
Lei sognava di essere su una nave
e che a un certo punto
la nave finisce nella tempesta
e il nocchiero della nave
che la guidava
sparisce nelle acque.
è suo marito che è scomparso,
lei è rimasta su questa nave,
la nave della sua famiglia,
disperata vorrebbe buttarsi in acqua
e affogarsi,
la trattengono,
la nave va alla deriva
e poi Cristina racconta
in questo sogno, dice,
dormivo,
sogna di dormire,
dormivo e mentre dormivo
la fortuna
mi è venuta vicino.
Notate che la fortuna
non è,
per questa gente del Medioevo,
banalmente come per noi,
la buona fortuna,
vinco il terno all'otto.
La fortuna è qualcosa
di più complesso,
è il cambiamento improvviso,
è quello che può succedere
e che ti cambia la vita,
questa è la fortuna,
che ti può portare in alto
o farti precipitare,
è una delle ossessioni
degli uomini di quest'epoca.
Come si fa in fretta a salire
e come si fa in fretta a precipitare.
Dunque Cristina sogna,
nel sogno sta dormendo,
arriva la fortuna
e comincia a palparla,
le palpa tutto il corpo,
la maneggia.
Poi nel sogno Cristina si sveglia.
La prima cosa di cui si accorge
è che ha perso l'anello nuziale.
La seconda cosa di cui si accorge
è che il suo corpo è cambiato,
che le membra sono più forti,
che la voce è più grossa,
Cristina sogna
che è diventata un uomo.
E un uomo non piange
quando arriva una disgrazia.
Cristina nel sogno
prende chiodi e martello
e comincia ad aggiustare la nave.
Ma io vorrei leggervi,
traducendo dal francese,
tutto quello che ha scritto Cristina
è in francese.
Traduco,
perché è interessante analizzare
proprio le precise parole
con cui lei descrive
questo suo cambiamento,
com'è diventata un uomo.
È interessante,
perché non tutto è ovvio.
Cristina dice
mi sentì
molto più leggera
del solito.
Notate questa cosa,
noi magari potrebbe venire da pensare
che un uomo
è più robusto
e quindi è più pesante
di una donna normalmente,
no?
E invece evidentemente
per una donna di allora,
una donna di allora percepisce
la pesantezza fisica
del suo essere donna
che fa bambini continuamente,
che è continuamente incinta
e invece un uomo
è più leggero.
Questa è una cosa
secondo me inaspettata
per noi.
E il mio volto era cambiato
e indurito,
questo va bene,
e la mia voce
si era fatta più profonda
e il corpo più forte
e snello,
di nuovo.
Una donna,
una mamma
che si immagina
di diventare uomo
si immagina di essere
non solo più forte
ma più snella.
mi ritrovai
con un animo forte
e ardito
di cui mi sorprendevo
e capì
di essere diventata
un vero uomo.
Dunque,
cosa vuol dire
essere diventato un uomo?
Il modo di descrivere
questa cosa
è straordinario
ma la realtà poi
non è così straordinaria.
Quante donne
rimanevano vedove?
Si moriva
a tutte le età
a quell'epoca.
Infinite donne
rimanevano vedove
e dovevano affrontare
tutti gli stessi problemi.
Rimettere in piedi
la baracca
scoprendo
che tutti gli affari
di famiglia
li conosceva il marito
e che finché c'era
il marito
la moglie
non si occupava
di niente.
Cristina deve cominciare
a rimettere in piedi
gli affari di famiglia
e ci sono i creditori
che arrivano
a pretendere
il pagamento
dei crediti
e lei va a cercarle
ricevute
e scopre
che i crediti
sono già pagati
però se lei
non trovava
la ricevuta
quelli
glielo facciamo
pagare di nuovo
tanto è una donna
la freghiamo
come vogliamo
poi ci sono
i debiti
da riscuotere
i crediti
voglio dire
da un lato
la famiglia
è indebitata
ma dall'altro
ha prestato
e anche lì
vai dai debitori
del marito
a farti pagare
Cristina scopre
che suo marito
segretario
del re
deve riscuotere
anni di stipendi
arretrati
tutto questo
non è affatto
strano
all'epoca
i funzionari
pubblici
prendono
buoni stipendi
ma non li vedono
mai
in realtà
prendono un sacco
di bustarelle
e vivono di quello
poi ogni tanto
uno decide
di farsi pagare
gli stipendi
arretrati
Cristina ci racconta
nelle sue opere
i giri
per gli uffici
dal tesoriere
dal vice tesoriere
dal segretario
da quello che deve
mettere la firma
da quello che ha
la pratica nel cassetto
e dice come è umiliante
tutto questo
tu sei una donna
da sola
questi sono uomini
spavaranzati nei loro uffici
e fanno le battute
e tu devi star lì
a far la fila
per farti pagare
quello che ti spetta
questo come dire
è un aneddoto
magari superficiale
conta poco
ma lo dico lo stesso
perché come dire
ha una sua attualità
Cristina a un certo punto
deve fare causa
allo Stato
per farsi pagare
gli arretrati
dello stipendio
di suo marito
vince la causa
dopo quattordici anni
dopo che ha vinto
la causa
passano altri
sette anni
prima che la tesoreria
effettivamente
le saldi
i crediti
degli stipendi
del marito
e Cristina
a un certo punto
su questo ragiona
e in una delle sue opere
scriverà
è abitudine
di tutti gli uomini
sposati
non parlare
dei loro affari
e non spiegarli
completamente
alla moglie
e questo
provoca spesso
conseguenze negative
come ho sperimentato
io stessa
e non è una cosa
di buon senso
un conto
se la moglie
è una stupida
ma se la moglie
è prudente
e saggia
è assurdo
che il marito
non le spieghi
i suoi affari
dopodiché
ripeto
fin qua
tante vedove
hanno affrontato
la stessa trafila
e bene o male
si sono arrangiate
perché noi parliamo
qua di Cristina
perché a Cristina
succede una cosa
invece
eccezionale
Cristina legge
anzi
appena rimasta vedova
una delle cose
che scopre
è che insieme
al dolore
di essere rimasta sola
però un po' più
di tempo di prima
ce n'è
lei ricomincia
a leggere
a un certo punto
ci pensa anche
certo
che se non fossi
rimasta vedova
ne avrei avuto
di meno
di tempo
per questa cosa
che è la mia
vera passione
legge dunque
legge
e come tanti
che leggono tanto
le viene anche
da scrivere
per qualche anno
scrive per sé
poesie
soprattutto
ballate
ballate di rimpianto
per il suo uomo
che è morto
ballate sulla solitudine
ballate su come
cambia la vita
quando meno
te lo aspetti
ecco appunto
e poi la sua vita
cambia di nuovo
quando meno
se lo aspetta
qualcuno legge
queste sue ballate
lei è una persona
ricordiamocelo
perché senza questo
non funzionerebbe niente
è legata ai potenti
è una famiglia
comunque che si muove
nel circolo
della corte
del re di Francia
ha le conoscenze giuste
a un certo punto
si viene a sapere
che lei scrive
che scrive queste ballate
vengono lette
vengono apprezzate
e com'è
come non è
qualcuno comincia
a dire a Cristina
ma perché non scrivi
un libro
su questo argomento
perché non scrivi
sulla fortuna
su come cambia
la vita
all'improvviso
tu che l'hai sperimentato
scrivi un libro
su questo
sarebbe bellissimo
e lei scrive
un libro su questo
e a corte piace
lo vogliono avere
se lo vogliono far copiare
e poi viene
il duca di Borgogna
uno dei più grandi
principi del regno
e le dice
tu quando eri bambina
hai conosciuto
il gran re
Carlo V
il saggio
il re di cui suo padre
era medico
e astrologo
io voglio far scrivere
un libro
sulla vita
del gran re
Carlo V
ci sono dei motivi
politici per questo
in Francia
i vari principi
sono in contesa
fra loro
e poter sostenere
da parte del duca
di Borgogna
che in fondo
lui è il vero erede
del gran re
Carlo il saggio
ecco
è una cosa
politicamente rilevante
il duca di Borgogna
dice
è un po' che cercavo
qualcuno
che potesse scrivermi
questo libro
scrivilo tu
qui c'è il sacchetto
di Franchi d'oro
se scriverai
il libro
e Cristina
si mette a intervistare
chi ha conosciuto
il gran re
e scrive
il libro
dei fatti
e detti
memorabili
del re Carlo V
il saggio
e continua
parentesi
è la prima donna
al mondo
che abbia scritto
un libro di storia
su commissione
e le commissioni
le committenze
cominciano a fioccare
e rapidamente
la sua fama
tra valica le Alpi
arriva anche in Italia
il suo paese natio
Gian Galeazzo Visconti
duca di Milano
a un certo punto
scrive a Parigi
dicendo
Cristina
vieni a Milano
perché alla mia corte
c'è un posto per te
lei decide di restare
in Francia
dove la stanno pagando
molto bene
allora
la faccio breve
ma avete capito
Cristina
diventa
rapidamente famosa
come la donna
scrittrice
la donna
che sa scrivere
e sa scrivere
di tutto
le chiede un libro
su un argomento
e lei scrive
e viene coperta
d'oro
notate che non si fa
illusioni
Cristina
lo dice più volte
nelle sue opere
non è una cosa
consueta
che una donna
scriva
ed è per questo
che i miei libri
piacciono tanto
perché ai principi
piacciono le cose
insolite
le cose bizzarre
ecco
è quasi una curiosità
e lei lo dice
lo so che è per questo
in realtà
che ho tanto successo
non tanto per il valore
di quello che scrivo
ma perché
una donna
che scrive
è una cosa
eccezionale
in questo mondo
ma quello che è davvero
eccezionale
è che Cristina
prende
estremamente sul serio
in modo
professionale
questa sua nuova realtà
questa sua nuova vita
così diversa
dalla precedente
quando dico professionale
intendo dire
uno
che lei
non fa più altro
che scrivere
le committenze
fioccano
e lei scrive
tutti i giorni
lei diventa
una scrittrice
professionista
scrive
trattati filosofici
trattati politici
trattati di storia
di araldica
di arte militare
consigli ai politici
analisi della situazione
del regno
riflessioni sulle riforme
e sulle tasse
ne parleremo fra poco
perché sono attualissime
nei primi sette anni
scrive
quindici opere
senza contare
le poesie d'occasione
eccetera
ce lo dice lei
ho riempito
in sette anni
70 quaderni
di grande formato
con le sue opere
e questo è il primo punto
scrive
ma
cosa vuol dire
scrivere
e pubblicare
un libro
siamo all'inizio
del quattrocento
ormai
lei direi
diventa famosa
nel 1399
quando le sue ballate
vanno in circolo
e per una quindicina
d'anni
è una scrittrice
di grande successo
cosa vuol dire
essere uno scrittore
di successo
pubblicare
un libro
non c'è la stampa
quindi tutti i libri
si scrivono a mano
e allora
pubblicare un libro
vuol dire
che tu
tu scrittore
presenti
al tuo mecenate
al re
al papa
al cardinale
al duca
presenti
il tuo libro
che è un esemplare
unico
all'inizio
poi chi vuole
se lo farà copiare
e se il libro
ha successo
saranno in tanti
a volere una copia
ma all'inizio
è un esemplare
unico
lussuoso
più devi presentarlo
a un grande personaggio
più ti aspetti
di essere pagato
più l'oggetto
sarà lussuoso
Caterina
non si limita
a scrivere
l'opera
ma produce
il manoscritto
non da sola
naturalmente
ha un'azienda
assume
dei copisti
professionali
assume
degli autori
di miniature
fra cui
almeno
una donna
ne riparleremo
e lei
progetta
quell'opera
d'arte
che è
il manoscritto
di ogni
sua opera
poi
gran parte
delle cose
le scrive
anche lei
sono stati
identificati
manoscritti
autografi
di Cristina
molti altri
li fa scrivere
in tutti
fa mettere
le miniature
e stabilisce
lei naturalmente
il piano
iconografico
in tutti
i suoi libri
fra le
illustrazioni
è sempre
raffigurata
anche lei
lei che
scrive
con la penna
d'oca
il calamaio
il raschietto
la sabbia
la pergamena
lei nel suo
studio
che legge
con i libri
tutti intorno
lei che
si inginocchia
davanti al re
e gli presenta
come fanno
gli artisti
il suo
manoscritto
lei è sempre
vestita
allo stesso
modo
con lo stesso
abito
la stessa
accoggiatura
riconoscibilissima
è lei
l'autrice
di bestseller
dell'epoca
fa qualcosa
che nessuna
donna
ha mai fatto
il che
non vuol dire
che si dimentichi
di essere
una donna
perché dico
questa cosa
che sembra
stupida
detta così
voi mi scuserete
per un motivo
molto preciso
lei a un certo
punto
racconta
cosa vuol dire
fare dei libri
partorire
dei libri
e lo dice
proprio così
fare dei libri
ha molto
in comune
col partorire
i bambini
chi di voi
c'era ieri sera
si ricorda
che anche
Caterina da Siena
usava questo tipo
di immagini
il parto
l'allattamento
perché evidentemente
faceva parte
del sapere
comune
di tutte le donne
questo
ma Cristina
parla in prima persona
lei li ha fatti
i bambini
e c'è un'opera
in cui lei
si immagina
di dialogare
con la natura
e la natura
le dice
sì adesso
hai cambiato
vita
ma non l'hai cambiata
così tanto
la natura
che dice a Cristina
all'epoca
in cui portavi
i bambini
nel ventre
sentivi
grandi dolori
al momento
di partorire
ora io voglio
è la natura
che parla
ora io voglio
che da te
nascano
dei nuovi libri
che conserveranno
il tuo ricordo
nel mondo
nei tempi
a venire
e per sempre
e partorirai
nella gioia
grazie alla tua
intelligenza
questo notate
è audacissimo
perché partorirai
con dolore
come dire
non si aggira
partorirai
con dolore
ma partorire
i libri
invece
no
i libri
si partoriscono
nella gioia
anche se il travaglio
c'è stato
la gravidanza
c'è stata
la grande fatica
ma poi il parto
è il momento
della gioia
e questo dunque
è diverso
ma poi Cristina
torna
all'analogia
tra l'autrice
che manda
il suo libro
nel mondo
e la mamma
che ha fatto
il bambino
malgrado
il travaglio
e il dolore
proprio come
la donna
che ha partorito
appena
sente
gridare
il bambino
dimentica
il suo male
tu dimenticherai
la fatica
e la pena
sentendo
il rumore
che si farà
intorno
ai tuoi libri
anche qui
l'analogia è forte
il bambino
piange
grida
e la mamma
appena lo sente
si dimentica
tutto
per
entrare
in questo suo nuovo ruolo
e così i libri
i libri gridano
o fanno gridare
la gente
la fanno parlare
e per la donna
che li ha partoriti
è un piacere
simile a quello
della donna
che ha partorito
il bambino
e che lo sente
vivo
e che se lo porta
al seno
piccola pausa
scusate
no vabbè
grazie
io vi ringrazio
ma garantisco
che non è un effetto
di spettacolo
bisogna bere
arrivati a un certo punto
allora
vi dicevo
che
Caterina
addio
lo sapevo
che mi sarei confuso
che Cristina
Cristina da Pizzano
Cristine de Pizan
come la chiamano
i suoi francesi
scrive
sugli argomenti
più diversi
e scrive
anche di politica
vive
un'epoca
tormentatissima
la Francia
è nel pieno
della guerra
dei cent'anni
il buon re
Carlo V
il saggio
di cui le fanno
scrivere
la biografia
è morto
da un pezzo
adesso regna
Carlo VI
il pazzo
nel senso
che ha degli attacchi
di follia
effettivamente
e a un certo punto
diventa incapace
di governare
il regno
e allora
chi governa
il regno?
suo fratello
il duca di Orlean
ma perché
non suo cugino
il duca di Borgogna
o lo zio
il duca di Berri
tutti questi principi
potentissimi
ricchissimi
sono in competizione
fra loro
per governare
il regno
ed è una competizione
che degenera
rapidamente
nel 1407
il reggente
del regno
il duca di Orlean
fratello del re
viene assassinato
la Francia
sprofonda
nella guerra civile
e mentre la Francia
sprofonda
nella guerra civile
il nemico
di sempre
gli inglesi
si rifanno
vivi
il re
d'Inghilterra
Enrico V
sostiene
che è lui
il legittimo
re di Francia
per una serie
di questioni
genealogiche
chi di voi
si ricorda
l'Enrico V
di Shakespeare
comincia proprio
con Enrico V
che consulta
i dotti
e i vescovi
tirano fuori
le genealogie
e gli dicono
si si
hai ragione
tu
il regno
di Francia
è tuo
dunque gli inglesi
attaccano
sbarcano
in Francia
i francesi
subiscono
una disfatta
spaventosa
la battaglia
di Azancur
è sempre
l'Enrico V
di Shakespeare
Cristina vive
in questi anni
vive in questi anni
in cui il dibattito
politico nel regno
è furibondo
e in modo particolare
il duca di Borgogna
alimenta
la critica
al governo
in carica
e attizza
le speranze
della gente
che le cose
possano cambiare
la speranza
di meravigliose
riforme
il duca di Borgogna
Giovanni
senza paura
è all'opposizione
è facilissimo
dire che va
tutto male
e che bisognerebbe
fare le riforme
vi dico
qual è il programma
di riforma
del duca di Borgogna
primo
soppressione totale
delle imposte
secondo
riduzione
dei funzionari
pubblici
terzo
impiccagione
dei finanzieri
corrotti
la gente
è entusiasta
Cristina
scrive
dei trattati
politici
delle analisi
della situazione
del regno
in questo contesto
e interviene
in questi dibattiti
la stessa donna
che ha detto
non ha senso
che il marito
non spieghi
i suoi affari
alla moglie
perché poi
il marito muore
e la moglie
non sa come fare
questa stessa donna
discute per esempio
il problema
delle tasse
ed è
l'unico
autore
della sua
epoca
che ha il coraggio
di dire
che le tasse
sono necessarie
e bisogna
pagarle
perché
all'epoca
i discorsi
attizzati
dal duca
ma ragazzi
queste sono
quelle cose
che stanno scritte
lì
se vedete
delle analogie
con il nostro
tempo
è la vostra
fantasia
che ve le suggerisce
ma
all'epoca
va detto
quasi tutti gli autori
sono contro
le tasse
imposte dal re
perché questa gente
del medioevo
viene da una lunga
epoca beata
in cui
il ragionamento
corrente era
il re
è straricco
sì
possiede
immense proprietà
terriere
che gli rendono
gigantesche rendite
quindi
che vivesse
di quello
non ha il diritto
di chiedere alla gente
di tirar fuori
i soldi suoi
questa è la convinzione
radicatissima
di generazioni
e generazioni
di nostri antenati
e ancora
all'epoca
di Cristina
quelli che si preoccupano
di scrivere
su questi argomenti
scrivono questo
le tasse
non sono giustificate
il re
è viva
delle sue proprietà
perché la brava gente
deve tirare fuori
i soldi
Cristina
è forse
l'unica
che scrive
ma ci sono
degli ottimi motivi
per cui dobbiamo
tirare fuori
i soldi
perché il re
deve difendere
il paese
e la paga lui
la guerra
per difendere
il paese
e il re
deve garantire
la giustizia
e la giustizia
costa
e di conseguenza
noi tutti
dobbiamo contribuire
c'è poco da fare
poi Cristina
dice anche
come è inevitabile
i funzionari
che riscuotono
le tasse
e poi fanno
sparire i soldi
quelli andranno
all'inferno
quella è una vergogna
e non è tollerabile
e poi affronta
l'altro grande argomento
che all'epoca
suscita enormi controversie
le esenzioni fiscali
perché in questo
stranissimo mondo
del primo quattrocento
i ricchi
trovano un sacco di modi
per non pagare
le tasse
e
e se sei nobile
non paghi le tasse
e quello
nemmeno Cristina
arriva a dire
che non sia
che sia sbagliato
no è giusto
non c'è niente da fare
e i nobili
va bene
i nobili fanno la guerra
pagano con loro sangue
sono argomenti
che verranno ripetuti
dai nobili in Francia
fino alla rivoluzione
francese
ma gli altri
guarda un po'
i segretari del re
a forza di sgomitare
hanno ottenuto
di non pagare le tasse
i funzionari pubblici
hanno ottenuto
di non pagare le tasse
e Cristina dice
ma questo è stupefacente
tutta questa gente
prende gli stipendi
dal re
e non vuole pagare
le tasse
anche se potrebbero
benissimo
sopportarlo
questo peso
e invece
i poveri
che dal re
non ricevono
nessun emolumento
sono obbligati
a pagare
questo
dice Cristina
è uno scandalo
dopodiché
rimane il fatto
che le tasse
bisogna pagarle
poi
a un certo punto
si discute
sulla nomina
dei funzionari pubblici
segretari
tesorieri
giudici
e Cristina dice
si si sono nominati
lo sappiamo tutti
come sono nominati
per amicizia
per clientela
ma perché
non li nominiamo
i consiglieri
del re
i funzionari
facendogli passare
un esame
così come si fa
all'università
per laureare
un dottore
in teologia
o in un'altra scienza
parentesi
immaginate
che effetto
fa questa cosa
agli storici francesi
di oggi
in Francia
con il culto
che loro hanno
della funzione pubblica
del funzionaire
e Christine de Pisan
che all'inizio
del quattrocento
dice
i funzionari pubblici
nominiamoli
con un esame
di stato
Françoise Autran
grande storica
della Sorbona
che ha scritto
una delle più recenti
importanti vite
di Cristina
dice
eh
Christine de Pisan
madre
della meritocrazia
repubblicana
punto interrogativo
ben inteso
ma insomma
queste sono le cose
che suscitano
tra i francesi
queste trovate
di Cristina
poi
cosa c'è di attualità
nel suo tempo
purtroppo
la guerra
la pace
è la guerra
e su questo
Cristina interviene
in molti modi
a seconda del momento
per la pace
innanzitutto
in un momento
cruciale
in cui sembra
che la guerra
stia per scoppiare
Cristina
scrive
un appello
alla pace
e lo indirizza
alla regina
di Francia
e alla regina
Cristina dice
io sono una donna
e scrivo a te
che sei una donna
quando c'è la guerra
chi la paga
più di tutti
le donne
e perciò
io mi appello
a te che sei la regina
e a tutte le donne
di Francia
per cercare
di scongiurarla
la guerra
però
però ci sono poi
anche i momenti
in cui invece
la guerra
è l'ora di farla
le controversie
tra i principi
stanno rovinando
il regno
e tra questi principi
uno
il duca di Borgogna
che ho già menzionato
prima
e che pure
ha pagato bene
a Cristina
uno dei suoi primi libri
la vita del re Carlo
ecco
il duca di Borgogna
sempre più chiaramente
tende a configurarsi
come un traditore
come uno
che pur di prendere
il potere
è disposto a allearsi
con gli inglesi
e allora
a un certo punto
contro il duca di Borgogna
gli altri principi francesi
vogliono fare la guerra
e stavolta
Cristina
ed è l'idea
che questa guerra
sarebbe giusto farla
cosa fa
un autore
di best seller
nell'anno
in cui si profila
all'orizzonte
una guerra giusta
pubblica un trattato
sull'arte della guerra
e che cosa ne sa
Cristina
dell'arte della guerra
lei lo scrive
nel suo libro
sono andata a intervistare
i cavalieri
gli uomini che la guerra
la conoscono
mi son fatto raccontare
da loro
e da loro
si è fatta raccontare
come si fanno
le tecniche degli assedi
e i nomi
dei vari tipi
di cannoni
e racconta
tutte queste cose
e scrive
un manuale
di arte militare
e poi
e poi a un certo punto
comincia a scrivere
le cose
per cui oggi
è più famosa
e per cui
è considerata
non del tutto
a torto
credo anche
un'antesignana
del femminismo
Cristina
comincia a scrivere
delle riflessioni
sul ruolo
della donna
nella società
del suo tempo
forse la prima volta
che parla di questo
è in un trattatello
indirizzato
al figlio
insegnamenti
per mio figlio
è un vecchio genere
e in passato
nel medioevo
ci sono state altre donne
che hanno scritto
insegnamenti
per il loro figlio
perché
questa sfera
dell'educazione
è una di quelle
che si riconosce
che alle donne
tocca effettivamente
le donne sono coinvolte
in questo
negli insegnamenti
per suo figlio
Cristina
comincia
a parlare
di come
bisogna trattare
le donne
e che cosa dice
al figlio
non ingannarle
le donne
non andare in giro
a sedurle
e poi magari
vantartene
non parlare
male delle donne
non fare come fanno
tutti gli altri uomini
che quando hanno bevuto
cominciano a ridacchiare
dire sì le donne
sanno solo parlare
sanno solo piangere
sono buone solo a letto
ecco non fare così
non ripeterle anche tu
queste stupidaggini
se sposi una donna
purché sia una donna saggia
perché se sposi una cretina
non c'è niente da fare
ma se sposi una donna saggia
dalle fiducia
nella gestione
della casa
deve essere padrona
dopo di te
non serva
non è la tua serva
ovviamente i tempi
sono quelli che sono
e che rimarranno ancora
per un sacco di tempo
per cui i consigli
di Cristina
al figlio
su come trattare
sua moglie
proseguono così
fai in modo
che tua moglie
ti rispetti
e ti obbedisca
ma non picchiarla
cosa che è necessario
dire evidentemente
anche se uno è figlio
di un intellettuale
e di un segretario
del re
è opportuno dirglielo
che la moglie
non bisogna picchiarla
ma Cristina lo dice
e poi nasce
un dibattito letterario
Cristina scatena
che i letterati
conoscono benissimo
si chiama
il dibattito
sul romando
e la rose
in cui Cristina
da sola
sfida
un certo numero
di umanisti
e di universitari
francesi
i più grandi
intellettuali
del suo tempo
perché sostiene
una posizione
contraria
alla loro
qual è il punto
è una storia
un po' noiosa
spero di farvela breve
nella letteratura
francese medievale
esiste questo grande romanzo
il romando
e la rose
che a quell'epoca
è già vecchio
è roba di 150 anni prima
ma è un testo
famosissimo
ce l'hanno tutti
in casa
l'han letto tutti
lo conoscono tutti
il romando e la rose
è un testo
straordinario
pieno di cose
di invenzioni
è un testo
fantastico
io devo dire che
dovessi scegliere
il romando e la rose
è infinitamente più interessante
di quasi tutte le opere
di Cristina
che Dio mi perdoni
ma comunque
è un testo
che fa l'elogio
del sesso
e dell'amore libero
certo
da un punto di vista
abbastanza maschilista
ma che fa un elogio
straordinario
della sessualità
è un testo
in cui si discute
del sesso
delle parti sessuali
del perché dovremmo
vergognarci
delle parti sessuali
e dice il romando
e la rosa
non dobbiamo vergognarci
ne ha fatto
non c'è nessun motivo
di vergognarci
è roba bellissima
l'ha fatta lui
e l'ha fatta
perché dobbiamo usarla
poi
ce l'ho il tempo
butto via 5 minuti
su questo
perché è una cosa
che a me interessa molto
e devo dire
vale la pena di raccontarla
e a Cristina
interessava molto
nel romando e la rosa
si avvia
questa discussione
a un certo punto
fra il protagonista
e la ragione
la figura
della ragione
una donna
anche lei
naturalmente
sulle parolacce
perché la ragione
parlando
si è lasciata scappare
una parolaccia
siccome lo fanno loro
nel tredicesimo secolo
lo faccio anch'io
e voi mi scuserete
la ragione
si è lasciata scappare
la parola coglioni
e il narratore
dice ma come
ma una signora
che usa queste parole
ma non esiste
e la ragione
gli dice
ah perché ti sembra
una brutta parola
e dice
si il narratore
certo che è una brutta parola
specialmente una donna
non dovrebbe usarle
queste parole
e la ragione
gli dice
ma sentiamo un po'
ma è una brutta parola
perché si applica
a quella cosa lì
ma guarda che quella cosa lì
è bellissima
l'ha fatta Dio
è necessaria
per la procreazione
allora il narratore
si fa incastrare
dice no ma è vero
non è la cosa
è la parola in sé
che è brutta
e la ragione
gli dice
ah la parola è brutta
ma guarda che le parole
sono convenzionali
guarda che è una scelta
casuale
se noi l'abbiamo chiamata così
e quella cosa lì
l'abbiamo chiamata
coglioni
ma potevamo chiamarla
reliquie
ecco
se l'avessimo chiamata
reliquie
tu sentendo la parola
diretti
ah che orrore
che brutta parola
mentre la parola
coglioni
ti sembrerebbe bellissima
perché a quel punto
indicherebbe
ecco
questo è il romano
della Rose
e insieme a tutto questo
c'è però anche
da parte di certi personaggi
un ripetere
con piacere
le solite vecchie battute
i soliti vecchi scherzi
sul fatto che le donne
appunto
no
l'ho già detto prima
non stiamo a ripeterlo
sono buone solo
a piangere
a chiacchierare
non confidare i tuoi segreti
alle donne
perché non li sanno mantenere
ecco Cristina
a un certo punto
pubblica degli interventi
per dire basta con questa roba
non se ne può più
io sospetto
siccome era una signora
molto ben educata
e colta
che anche tutta la parte
sulle parolacce
e sul libero sesso
a lei non piacesse tanto
tutto sommato
e anche quello
che
però lei
attacca in modo particolare
il ripetere
fastidiosi luoghi comuni
sull'inferiorità
delle donne
e quando certi
intellettuali
le dicono
ma come ti permetti
di attaccare il romano
della rosa
il capolavoro
della nostra letteratura
e Cristina dice
ma vabbè
sarà anche un capolavoro
ma voi vedete
che continua a ripetere
queste cose
anche voi le ripetete
non ci pensate
un attimo
si dice sempre
la donna è questo
la donna è quello
ma di chi parliamo
scrive Cristina
e si sta rivolgendo
ai più autorevoli
intellettuali
del suo tempo
quando dite
la donna sa fare
solo questo
ma fammi capire
stiamo parlando
di tua madre
di tua sorella
stiamo parlando
di tua figlia
oppure è sempre
la donna così
in generale
e questi rispondono
ma insomma
il romano della rosa
comunque è un grande
capolavoro
è pieno di cose
istruttive
e qui viene fuori
Cristine de Pisan
che in realtà
si ricorda benissimo
di essere Cristina
da Pizzano
e di essere nata
in Italia
e gli dice
ma volete leggere
dei libri
veramente istruttivi
che vale la pena
di leggere
ma leggete Dante
non state a leggere
queste vecchie stupidaggini
del romano della rosa
dopodiché
a forza di riflettere
e di discutere
anche pubblicamente
su queste cose
Cristina decide
e stavolta
non è una committenza
che venga da fuori
lo decide lei
decide di scrivere
un libro
che la faccia finita
con i luoghi comuni
e con le stupidaggini
sull'inferiorità
della donna
decide di scrivere
un libro
che si chiamerà
la città delle donne
la città delle dame
in cui lei
dimostrerà
l'importanza
delle donne
nella storia
e per la vita
dell'umanità
e questo libro
si apre
con una scena
molto personale
spesso Cristina
si rappresenta
nei suoi libri
parla di sé
dice come è che ho deciso
di scrivere questo libro
è sera
lei è a casa
stanca
perché ha lavorato
tutto il giorno
una cosa difficile
adesso è sera
e stanca
vuole rilassarsi
e nel suo studio
in mezzo ai libri
dice adesso mi leggo
un libro divertente
tira giù
dallo scaffale
un libro
che sa che è divertente
è un libro
che si chiama
Le lamentazioni
di Matteo Luss
ed è un libro
esiste davvero
appartiene a un genere
che era molto fortunato
di libri comici
dell'epoca
i lamenti
dell'uomo sposato
che dice agli altri uomini
non sposatevi
perché non sapete
che roba è il matrimonio
è un genere
che ha successo
Cristina sa
che è un libro
di quel tipo
ma ha voglia
di divertirsi
lo apre
poi dice
in quel momento
è arrivata mia mamma
a bussare
dice Cristina
la cena è pronta
l'ho rimesso via
il libro
e sono andata a cena
il mattino dopo
torna nello studio
si ricorda
di quel libricino
che non ha più letto
la sera prima
solo che adesso
è di tutt'altro umore
rispetto a prima
adesso è mattina
lei è bella sveglia
aggressiva
tira giù questo libro
comincia a leggere
e non le viene
da ridere per niente
trova i soliti
luoghi comuni
guai
tua moglie
una rovina
prima eri il libro
adesso che sei sposato
puoi non fidarti di lei
e ti spende tutto
e pensa solo ai vestiti
legge tutta questa roba
e a un certo punto
le viene male
e pensa
ma quanti libri ci sono
che ripetono queste stupidaggini
e gli uomini
se le ripetono
e ci credono
ma com'è possibile
questa cosa
perché tutti ripetono
che la donna è debole
perché il proverbio
che tutti conoscono
in Francia è
Dio fece le donne
per piangere
parlare
e filare
ma com'è possibile
a un certo punto
le viene veramente male
a un momento di debolezza
si rivolge a Dio
e gli dice
ma Dio
ma perché
non mi hai fatto nascere
maschio
in realtà
poi sta barando
Cristina
non è un momento
di scoramento
perché questa battuta
questo rimprovero
rivolto a Dio
continua così
perché non mi hai fatto
nascere maschio
così da non sbagliare
in nulla
ed essere perfetta
in tutto
come gli uomini
dicono
di essere
infatti ci ripensa subito
è un'autrice medievale
pensa per allegorie
al suo pubblico
piacciono queste cose
e quindi le appaiono
la ragione
la rettitudine
e la giustizia
che ovviamente
sono tre donne
cari lettori
non c'è niente da fare
sono tre donne
lo vedete anche voi
e queste tre donne
le dicono
Cristina
qui ora di farla finita
la devi scrivere tu
l'opera
che la faccia finita
con queste stupidaggini
contro le donne
la devi costruire tu
questa città fortificata
in cui tutte le donne
possano trovare riparo
e qui lo so
che per il nostro gusto
queste immagini
queste metafore
queste allegorie
a noi sembrano pesanti
anche quelle di Dante
facciamo un po' fatica
ad accettarle in genere
però in certi casi
sono efficaci
questo libro
è una città fortificata
e Cristina
si fa rappresentare
dai suoi
miniatori di fiducia
nelle miniature
del manoscritto
che è lì
con la cazzuola
e le pietre
che costruisce
la città
e chi scrive
sa che scrivere un libro
è un po' come costruire
un edificio
e quindi in questo caso
l'immagine
è assolutamente calzante
dunque Cristina
costruisce la città
e cosa ci scrive
nel suo libro
la città delle donne
tante cose
tira fuori
tutte le donne
della Bibbia
e della storia
che hanno fatto
qualcosa di importante
e racconta le loro vite
e va benissimo
e poi
riflette
e su cosa riflette
qualche esempio
ci sono pochissime donne
dotte
i dotti
sono tutti uomini
gli intellettuali
e gli uomini
ci dicono
eh come mai
solo uomini
dotte
e le donne
no
e Cristina dice
ma ragazzi
perché le bambine
non vanno a scuola
ma se voi
mandaste a scuola
le bambine
se le bambine
potessero studiare
si vedrebbe
che non c'è
nessuna differenza
e lei dice
anche qualcosa
di più
ci sono dei casi
di uomini
dotti
che hanno fatto
studiare
le loro figlie
mio padre
per esempio
e anche altri
racconta di un giurista
dell'università
di Bologna
che aveva fatto
studiare
sua figlia
diritto
e quella
era così brava
che sostituiva
il papà
a lezione
già allora
i baroni
ogni tanto
evidentemente
appunto
si facevano
e Cristina dice
non sono i dotti
il vero problema
che impedisce
alle donne
di studiare
sono la massa
degli uomini
ignoranti
che non sopporterebbero
di vedere una donna
che ne sa più
di loro
e poi
l'altra cosa
che dice
è
non è solo
la società
non permette
alle donne
di studiare
Cristina dice
anche un'altra cosa
se le donne
volessero
studiare
allora
vedreste
che cambierebbe
tutto
quindi non è
soltanto
come dire
la lamentela
contro una società
patriarcale
che lo impedisce
ma è la consapevolezza
che le donne
stesse
sono prese
dentro questa
trappola
e che sono loro
le prime
che devono
voler cambiare
poi
il progresso
qui forse
dovrei fare
una piccola
parentesi
perché
come dire
nell'immagine
corrente del
medioevo
il progresso
non è la prima
cosa che ci viene
in mente
di accostare
al medioevo
invece diciamolo
una buona volta
il medioevo
specialmente
il basso
medioevo
questi ultimi
secoli
del medioevo
sono un'epoca
di prosperità
di ottimismo
e di immensa fiducia
nell'umanità
e nel progresso
e Cristina dice
certo
noi viviamo
in una società
incredibilmente
progredita
pensate rispetto
agli uomini primitivi
cosa abbiamo noi
tutte le cose
che noi abbiamo
dice Cristina
adesso facciamo
l'elenco
le hanno inventate
le donne
in un modo
o nell'altro
e va avanti
la scrittura
il calcolo
l'agricoltura
il pane
l'olio d'oliva
gli orti
i giardini
le case
le città
il lavoro
della lana
del lino
l'invenzione
della ruota
perfino
l'invenzione
del ferro
e delle armi
Cristina
che ha una buona biblioteca
è andata a leggersi
mitologia antica
ne ha trovati
tanti di miti
in cui
all'origine
di qualche cosa
c'è una donna
che ne so
la filatura
Aracne
il mito di Aracne
che per prima
ha imparato
l'arte del filare
e l'ha insegnata
agli uomini
e così via
tutto il resto
e Cristina dice
sono le donne
che hanno fatto
progredire il mondo
le donne hanno condotto
il mondo
dalla bestialità
a vita umana
e ragionevole
e poi oltre ai concetti
astratti
il concreto
voi dite che le donne
non sono bravi
quanto gli uomini
ma io
ho avuto al mio servizio
una pittrice
un'autrice di miniature
per i miei manoscritti
Anastasia si chiamava
più brava
dei più bravi artisti
uomini
lei mi ha fatto
delle miniature
che quelli che le hanno viste
hanno detto
che erano uniche
che non c'era
nessun altro artista
capace di fare
cose del genere
e dunque
ma anche altro
per dire
c'è un punto
in cui rapidamente
Cristina
tocca
il tema
della violenza sessuale
e tocca il fatto
che gli uomini
di fronte
alla violenza sessuale
sono subito
pronti a dire
ma sì
ma in fondo
se l'è voluta
anzi
ma in fondo
le è piaciuto
alle donne piace
Cristina
ha il coraggio
di toccare
questo tema
e di dire
ma vi rendete conto
cosa state dicendo
ma voi credete
veramente
che ci possa
piacere
ecco
Cristina
tocca questi temi
e conclude
dicendo
non voglio più
sentirle
tutte queste banalità
sulle donne
vergognatevi
che stiano zitti
e che vadano
a cuccia
tutti quelli
che sanno solo
ripetere
che le donne
sono buone
soltanto a piangere
a parlare
e così via
dopodiché
Cristina
molto concretamente
scrive ancora
un altro libro
sulle donne
dove stavolta
si rivolge
alle donne
e gli dice
donne
bisogna imparare
a far vedere
quanto noi contiamo
al mondo
ognuno
nella sua posizione
parlo alla principessa
alla regina
sappi che può capitare
che tuo marito
non sia disponibile
e che tu devi governare
il regno
devi saper governare
alla moglie
del barone
del castellano
dell'uomo d'armi
devi conoscerle
quelle cose
devi essere in grado
di gestirle
come e quanto
tuo marito
alla moglie
del borghese
del mercante
devi conoscere
gli affari
la bottega
devi saperlo fare
quanto tuo marito
poi va scendendo
la società
va discendendo
arriva fino
alla prostituta
dice
guarda che si può
anche lavorare
per vivere
qui le scappa
di dire
guarda anch'io
lavoro per vivere
per esempio
poi dice
certo non è che tu
puoi metterti
a scrivere libri
ma guarda che ci sono
tanti lavori
che si possono fare
anche se una
ignorante
analfabeta
puoi fare la lavandaia
puoi fare l'assistenza
ai malati
non dice la badante
ma ci siamo vicinissimi
sostanzialmente
e dunque Cristina
gli ultimi libri
che scrive
sono libri militanti
espressamente
rivolti a una società
patriarcale
e alle sue donne
per dire
sono tutte
storie
quelle che circolano
sul fatto
che le donne
non sono
all'altezza
degli uomini
siamo alla fine
Cristina
ha una
quindicina
d'anni
di grande
successo
poi a un certo
punto
la situazione
politica
in Francia
degenera
veramente
e arriva
alla catastrofe
l'ho detto
prima
nel 1415
i francesi
sono sbaragliati
ad Asa
in Curda
Enrico V
a questo punto
una parte
della Francia
passa con gli inglesi
la città di Parigi
l'università di Parigi
la Sorbona
passa con gli inglesi
il duca di Borgogna
Enrico V
entra a Parigi
e viene incoronato
re di Francia
chi non è d'accordo
rischia la pelle
ci sono momenti
di pulizia
non etnica
ma politica
in cui
nelle strade di Parigi
si sgozza la gente
e il partito inglese
è al potere
e Cristina
sente che lei
non ci sta
che lei sta
dall'altra parte
sta col delfino
col giovanissimo
erede del regno
il quale è in condizione
di inferiorità
ha perso mezza Francia
ma la Francia è lui
Cristina sta con lui
e sa che per lei
restare a Parigi
è pericoloso
chiude
il suo periodo
di donna
che vive
una vita di intellettuale
in pubblico
se ne va in monastero
è anziana
ormai
ha passato i 50 anni
all'epoca vuol dire
essere pronti
per cominciare
a pensare alla morte
se ne va in monastero
per carità
in un bellissimo monastero
ricchissimo
dove l'abadessa
è una figlia del re
dove quindi si vive
tutt'altro che in penitenza
però si rinchiude
in questo monastero
come tanti facevano
all'epoca
arrivati a una certa età
per passare gli ultimi anni
della vita
a pregare
a far penitenza
e ad aspettare
di vedere cosa succede
rimane per un po' di anni
in monastero
si è ritirata
in questo monastero
nel 1418
quando i borgognoni
hanno preso Parigi
e hanno cominciato
a ammazzare la gente
ci rimane 11 anni
poi nel 1429
dopo 11 anni
di silenzio
all'improvviso
Cristina
scrive ancora
un libro
che è il suo
ultimo libro
e scrive
questo libro
che si chiama
il poema
di Giovanna d'Arco
perché in quel
nel suo monastero
come in tutta la Francia
è arrivata la notizia
che è comparsa
all'improvviso
una ragazzina
che è animata
da spirito profetico
e che è mandata
da Dio
per salvare la Francia
e questa ragazzina
sta sconfiggendo
gli inglesi
sul campo di battaglia
allora Cristina
prende la penna
e da grande professionista
scrive un instant book
che pubblica
immediatamente
mentre Giovanna
sta passando
di vittoria
in vittoria
Cristina pubblica
il poema
di Giovanna d'Arco
che comincia così
io Cristina
che ho pianto
per 11 anni
chiusa in abbazia
ora per la prima volta
rido
rido di gioia
perché è comparsa
Giovanna d'Arco
e la comparsa
di Giovanna d'Arco
vuol dire due cose
uno
che Dio
non ha abbandonato
il bel regno di Francia
e che le cose
andranno ancora
a finire bene
forse
e due
ancora più importante
vuol dire
che avevo ragione
io
perché è una donna
che sta salvando
il regno di Francia
è una donna
che sta facendo
quello che non si è mai sentito
combatte alla testa
degli eserciti
e sconfigge
i nemici
che onore
per il sesso
femminile
Cristina
chiude così
la sua vita
per quanto ne sappiamo
muore prima
che la vicenda
di Giovanna d'Arco
vada a finire
molto male
muore nel momento
del trionfo
nel momento in cui
la storia sta cambiando
improvvisamente corso
e in cui
in cui lei
a 65 anni
ha di colpo
la sensazione
che ha sempre
avuto ragione
e che la storia
ma lei avrebbe detto
Dio
le sta dando ragione
che il sesso femminile
vale quanto
quello maschile
se non di più
dopodiché
e su tutto questo
ovviamente
c'è da raccontare
la storia
di Giovanna d'Arco
ma quella
la racconteremo
domani sera
grazie
grazie a tutti
grazie mille
e buonanotte
grazie a tutti